μετοπού βρίσκεσαι διαβάσεις για αφορετικά αυτή την επιτυχία εγώ θα σας πω ότι από εκεί
που βρίσκομε η επιτυχία οφίλεται αποκλειστικάστο ότι ενοείναι η μικρατικός οργανισμός λειιτουργεί σε μεγάλο βαθμός
σαν ίδιοτικός οπότε τι είναι το μιστικών της επιτυχίας είναι να έχισε ένα οργανισμόύ μια
ανεταιρεία η οποία μπορεί να νι διοκτήτη στο κράτος δεν μπορεί το κέρδος του οργανισμού
να πηγαίνει στο κράτος αλάο ιδιοκτεί της δεν πρέπει να αναμιγνίεται να με τοπως τρέχει
ργανισμός και να φήνεται να λειτουργεί με τους κανόνες της αγοράς όσο περισότερον καταφέρει κάποιος
να πετύχει αυτή την ισορροπία τόσο πιο επιτυχημένος θαείσαι και δε χρειάζεσαι ι διοτιοκοποιήσεις αλλά
χρειάζει σίγουρα μεταριθμίσεις δεν μπορείς δηλαδή με το παλιώ το μοντέλον το επικρατηκού οργανισμού που
έγινε το εξύντα να επιδιώσει στο διο λιεςκο τέρα σαν ημικρατηγός και αυτό πράπτο καταλάβουν
όλοι αντο συσίδα παραδοσιακά είχε την κουλτούρα και στο προσωπικν και σε όλα να είναι
μια οικογένεια και να ασχολείται με το προσωπικό τολό γτο λέ εγώ που οικογένεια μου
όλοι σχεδόν πέρασεν από τη ήταν και βλόπου ακόμηι ότι τα οφελήματα που έχουν πλέον
σας συνταξεοχι είναι παράπολλκαι βλέπω ότι οργανισμός από μόνο του νιάζεται για το προσωπικώ το
οποίο πέρασε αλλά και περνά από των οργανισμο νομίζω υπάρχει αυτόν που λέτεκαι σίγουραφου το
ξέρετα και πυυ πρωτοχαιρι όμως αυτό που θέλω από είαι ότι ναι σίγουρα υπάρχει μια
σχέση μεταξύ του οργανισμού και του προσωπηκού η σχέση αυτή είναι λίγο έψεισαν μια αλληλο
εξάρτηση ο οργανισμός χρειάζεται προσωπηκών που να νιώθει ικανοποιημένω και να νιώσει ότι είναι μότιδα
είτα δηλαδή καινητοποιημένω να έρχεται κάθε